[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know why he's how you know he's
hostile why he just got out of jail he
stormed the stage at dave chappelle
was that you doc [ __ ] no no it looked
like you i was like
dude they beat the [ __ ] out of that guy
oh good did you see the pictures of this
guy
no bring up the photo of this guy look
at the guy that stormed this [ __ ] guy
you know what happened after it was over
they gave him a couple more
you know yeah they gave him a couple
more i don't know exactly what happened
i just know that he was assaulted what
do we do with this as comics i think
there's probably more security like
really high level shows yeah i think you
got to set the president of beating the
[ __ ] out of people who walk on stage how
does bro get through with the gun knife
dc on flight
and it didn't go back to jokes like
stood there and let everybody know like
i will [ __ ] all y'all up but you got it
with that thing yeah i love him how are
you getting with that yeah that's
ridiculous the hollywood bowl
you know what i mean that's [ __ ] wild
though yeah that is absolutely
ridiculous that's crazy this is from tmz
i think he has mental issues so there's
a part of me aside from the weapon that
i actually i saw this sadness in his
eyes
but jesus christ his [ __ ] arms look
like you know
you guys ever see toy story what sid
does to his toys that's what his arms
look like it was just uh
i don't know that kid needs help i hope
he gets help i hope he does but um
anyways
shout out to the [ __ ] that still
brought their cell phones in and still
filmed it's just [ __ ] ridiculous man
and you just can't do a show without
somebody filming it on some level
um
i don't know put your cell phones in the
bags and just sit there like adults is
that so [ __ ] hard no man i gotta film
it man
i gotta get likes man i gotta get some
friends on my [ __ ] account man
but then again we also don't build
anything in this country anymore not
true
u-turn
turntables
headstrong amplifiers
marijuana
all right we do make things
in this country you just gotta go out
you gotta go find it i had already seen
chappelle and so at the bowl and so this
is his fourth night or something so i
was like hey our buddy our good buddy
chuck scar who's one of chris's favorite
writers goes you going to the bowl
tonight i'm like oh no you know i
already saw him he's like you should go
rock is going up i'm like what
and so i immediately had just left you
and adam and said
let's go this will be his first la
appearance that i know of since the slap
and so
chris rock is present when another
person charges the stage attacking a
comedian
thank god chappelle had his own security
and not [ __ ] chris rock's security
rock needs to look into that detail
they're a little bit more excited about
their jobs than chris rock's guys are
yeah i don't really care what your
detail is you could be like uh you know
the premiere of uh israel
no one is anticipating
will smith charging the stage and
slapping you
i think they could have been laxed there
if chappelle
had been hosting
or presenting at the oscars and will
smith smacked him chappelle's guys would
have come out and smacked the [ __ ] out
of will smith i guarantee that yeah i
think that will smith should you know
we're not like oh come it's just like it
did
it put a rift in like the zeitgeist of
culture you know what i mean like it did
something i don't know what but it did
something and the fact that that dave
chappelle thing happened right after
it's like it did something yep there was
a move it moved that guy isn't doing
that to dave if will didn't do that
first i agree and he knew he was going
to get lumped the [ __ ] up but it was
worth the lumping for the attention it
was going to give him and people are
willing to take these shots for
attention they saw nothing he goes oh
that's actually maybe the worst thing
that nothing happened will if will
got lumped up emotionally or in some way
opposite enough to happen yo he got
celebrated you sat there they all
clapped they had a [ __ ] standing
ovation for him
chris so and that is on chris and that
is on [ __ ] chris so so yo chris is
partially responsible for this happening
no no no no no no no no no no no what i
mean is he's not responsible this guy
doing that to dave but the fact that
like no no pressing charges might have
been corny or something like that but
just like yo you can't come to oscar for
10 years whatever corny [ __ ] that was
like that means you get all the
attention all the adulation because
please believe there are people in
certain communities that are saying that
guy that attacked dave
he's a hero oh yeah he's a hero so he
got all the love and attention from the
people that he wants the love and
attention from he don't want it from the
haters he wants it from the celebrators
right so he got all the love intention
he wants now he got lumped the [ __ ] up
and it needs to be extra on top of that
like dude got to go to jail
or is this going to keep happening
what is the price you're willing to pay
for the clout if the price is low which
it was in bill smith uh will smith's
case other people are willing to pay
that price too i just walk around
slapping people and nothing happens to
me [ __ ] that's why they stopped showing
literally why they stopped showing
streakers during sports games like with
some other streaks because they're like
oh we don't have enough punishment for
this but if we keep showing this it's
going to happen so much more yeah so now
every that's why it don't happen as much
anymore because every time it happens
they don't show it at all you know just
the camera will just shift or go to
commercial immediately same thing for
fights in the stands at boxing matches
it's great to be here tonight so thank
you very much for your participation
oh jesus what the
holy crap oh
i'm sorry i thought i saw a guy coming
up here
[Applause]
was it it's just a waiter
oh
i'm so sorry it's just been a little
alarming you know what i mean
let's get one thing straight in
deference to the other performers
tonight and by the way
uh now we're talking about a comedy
festival because we have comics coming
out for you tonight and that's a
tremendous idea as as a in deference to
the
people coming out here let me just say
this when the show is finished
i will be in the lobby
and if anybody wants to come and beat me
up
my god come on out
how many of you would like to hit me
right now oh my god okay
and why did you
why did he face why did he do it well i
don't know motive yet but apparently
somebody said he had oh [ __ ] you don't
a bobby lee assault nothing will happen
yeah yeah attack bobby because at his
show he'll just give you a hug
yeah yeah but this guy got caught up in
the matrix
what's that called in black culture when
that happens to this guy doc
beat down getting beat down
you're getting beat the [ __ ] down
yeah well here's here's the deal so he
tackles dave and apparently he's got
like a knife and or something that looks
like a gun or a knife i i can't i don't
know the details
and dave got out of the way
good timing on dave dodged this was a
psychotic episode this is not normal
behavior you're 23 years old
23 are you that triggered well i
wouldn't even
pre-meditate that's not even like you
know a crime of passion where you're
like in the moment and dave says
something to trigger you at that moment
that you run on stage you plotted this
you brought a fake gun and a knife
you were just waiting for the right
opportunity talking about that psychotic
episode
no no the psychotic episode right that's
kind of interesting this is why this
will continue to happen
people will continue to have psychotic
breaks and now they have an outlet for
that psychosis
attacking a comedian just wasn't
something existed so they don't think
about doing it they're like oh let me
shoot up a school or let me go yell at
people on the street or let me go jump
in a [ __ ] dumpster or something this
is just another thing you can do now you
know what i'm saying like the school
shooting [ __ ] became a trend
it's not like it always existed
throughout history
[Applause]
so this is a new tick tock challenge
essentially for crazy people crazy
people are going to start to see that
this is something you can do and can get
attention for and you're fighting the
good fight or whatever and once that
psychosis starts spinning there's really
no stopping it yeah so 100 that's going
to happen again also what's really
interesting to me is the at any level
we're talking about the oscars and the
hollywood bowl yeah
you know what i'm saying because in your
head as a comic you do like like i said
when that if you know the funny bone
you're getting killed yeah exactly but
i'm not expecting that too i'm like
there's nobody in the security but i'm
at the hollywood security don't even
tell them to stop talking you gotta go
yo can you tell us table seven
to shut the [ __ ] up please let's do it
and i gotta kick them out from one state
like
you are done bro are you in a tux at the
hollywood bowl bro you there is a level
of like all right this i'm beyond that
now yeah no one's gonna run up here yup
so that's what's crazy to me is that
like bro the boldness to do this [ __ ] at
any kind of venue is like huh well
that's definitely new getting up on them
stages isn't easy
like those stages of the theater like
that [ __ ] like hike your pants every
time every time we're on the team
every time we're at a theater they put
security standing up on stage you go i
don't want them standing i don't like
them
i like them to be something else now
they're going to be there with me
sit right there
[ __ ] sitting at the cocktail
table
that's going to be my security air
marshal
but it's just like some guy that's
hanging out on the stage like a
photographer but he's strapped yeah yeah
secret photographer and i've been taking
pics yo that's great right 100 yeah now
remember i'm a stand-up comedian myself
so i've got skin in the game and
remember we're all still sort of
adjusting and evaluating what happened
around will smith do you remember for a
couple of days no one really wanted to
say that was wrong we did a video about
it at the time and i was like this is a
bit weird because i really like will
smith he's lovely but it can't be right
to attack someone on stage can it damn
man they ran up on stage
i was incensed
thank you for james jamie foxx you're
never in trouble if you're ever in
trouble jamie foxx will show up with a
sheriff head
and all the other comedians just stood
there they're waiting on me to die
take over i'll see you chris rock
it'll never happen
didn't he have something happen at a
show rogan
the lights went out and just how serious
that was
just that moment of like [ __ ] because he
was on stage and you could just you
could feel it from him too just like
[ __ ] like yeah because it's like
a joker in this [ __ ] like yeah it's
really happening like it's china in this
[ __ ]
whoever's mad at this [ __ ] today
because people
hate him
for real and hate and psychosis is a
terrifying thing and that's the thing
that happened with with chappelle it's
[ __ ] start day for the first
time in my life people started to hate
him it was different when he went to
africa [ __ ] didn't hate him
they're like is he crazy like what's
going on yeah this was
hate yeah
and if you're a crazy person and you're
filled with hate yeah that's a dangerous
combination there's also like a god
thing
because i think a lot of things look joe
like a god too expensive yeah exactly
like dave is like a hero he's a goat
he's like bigger than a human being but
he's also hated by some people and like
there's like a rift you know what i mean
i feel like crazy people for how much he
celebrated those people that hate him
hate him even more now maybe yeah do you
think he'll ptsd from that dave yeah no
oh no because he seems traumatic though
it looks like he won do you know what i
mean i know but still
he did win yeah i mean i understand that
it just feels like dave is like
i don't know maybe his security will get
tighter
no one will be able to access the stage
period now yeah how i just i just don't
understand how because i've like been to
like a cure concert
and like how do i get up there to attack
robert smith
i wouldn't but i'm just saying how would
you even be able to do it i mean use the
hollywood bowl you've been you can walk
right up to the stage yeah oh i see i
think i think what you can do is
we're giving tips on how to do this
yeah you know uh as every comedian that
hit very deeply and and what my biggest
fear without commenting on specifically
what those issues were my particular
issue was you know
40 years in the business my biggest fear
was not 40 years ago was not getting a
laugh was somebody not liking what i
said was maybe somebody being offended
and confronting me outside and going you
know that joke was really offensive and
then cancel culture came along and then
it was like oh my god if somebody
doesn't like your joke or you
overstepped a line you could lose your
career
and then after the academy awards i said
you know this is this violence triggers
violence and this is one step that kind
of opens a door and triggers somebody
that if they don't like what you're
saying or they're offended by what
you're saying
they are now um
it's kind of okay because it's been done
to be violent and then and that's what
my fear was and then watching what
happened to dave last night confirmed my
fear and i turned to my wife i you know
i was watching it kind of live on
twitter and i turned to my wife and i
said i don't want to i don't want to go
on stage i'm just i'm really afraid i
mean dave chappelle didn't say the guy
was a trans guy and if he is a trans guy
he identified as ass beaten today i'll
tell you that that was for sure
[Music]
you